buenos días martín vizcarra va a invocar
el artículo 113 en la constitución
política peruana que establece que el
presidente solamente puede ser
destituido por incapacidad física o
moral por retirarse del territorio
peruano sin autorización del parlamento
o por retornar fuera de tiempo también
va a emplear en su defensa el artículo
117 de la carta magna que señala que el
presidente en ejercicio solamente puede
ser juzgado durante su mandato por
traición a la patria por impedir la
realización de las elecciones por
disolver irregularmente el parlamento o
por no permitir el funcionamiento de los
organismos electorales la posición de
martín vizcarra es que él no ha cometido
delitos y que se somete a las
investigaciones de la fiscalía pero sin
que se interrumpa su mandato francisco
seco conseguirá el congreso de perú los
87 votos que se requieren para lograr
esta vacancia presidencial además le
pregunto cuáles serían los escenarios
que se pueden presentar el día de hoy
fuentes del parlamento me dijeron que en
las últimas horas los congresistas que
impulsan la vacancia presidencial
contaban con 70 votos de los 130
congresistas que conforman el
legislativo peruano y que solamente
necesitaban 17 votos mientras que en la
otra orilla se encontraban 40
congresistas que se oponen a la vacancia
presidencial y que el mandatario
solamente le requería cuatro votos para
mantenerse en el cargo pero en las
últimas horas medios locales difundieron
whatsapp mensajes del teléfono del ex
ministro de agricultura josé hernández
donde se probaría que el presidente de
martín vizcarra se habría reunido con
personas que lo acusan de recibir
sobornos por más de seiscientos mil
dólares por la construcción de un
proyecto de irrigación y de un hospital
el mandatario ha rechazado estas
conversaciones pero esto va a influir en
los votos de los congresistas a las 10
de la mañana se inicia la sesión del
parlamento y después de unas horas
conoceremos si martín vizcarra sobrevive
o no a este segundo proceso de
destitución
así es francisco por supuesto vamos a
estar entonces
pendientes a lo que ocurre en perú con
este proceso que sea el que se va a
adelantar al presidente martín vizcarra
en el congreso de ese país será
francisco zacarías nuestro corresponsal
desde el